[Music]
there are
no players on the floor the clock hit
zero
[Music]
the nba playoffs have arrived
[Music]
is
so luckily playoffs are underway and
while the games are fun
there are a couple series that look like
they have the potential to end up being
some sweeps
get out the brooms folks all righty
headed to
sixers celtics game one for them
hey jason we wish we were there and the
bubble with you
to support you but now that you have our
1 000
support from home one two
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gordon hayward went down with an injury
in game one
against the sixers after the game brad
stevens said it was a sprained ankle
sprained ankle don't know the severity
but he's clearly in pain and looked like
it had some swelling already
but then we saw gordon walk out with
crutches
so fingers crossed it isn't too bad but
doesn't look great
[Music]
on ten
[Music]
one of the best things to do at the end
of these long days you see these heels
it's not going to work as i get to the
bus pro tip
you always always always
have flats you don't care about that you
can throw off
we got a bus to catch
hey jimmy so you have been playing great
basketball
you seem to be having fun out there
you're winning what is it about the
miami heat specifically that has allowed
you to thrive at this level
i get to beat me i need to cuss people
out when they're not doing their job
i'm going cussing out and if i'm not
doing mine we're going to take nothing
personal you know it's on to the next
play because
everybody knows that whenever i say
something i mean well
it may not come out the right way about
being well and it goes that way across
the board
there are so many games so many
practices happening every single day but
we still
are in the midst of some competitive
playoff series
we've got um bucks magic who need to
continue their games there's lakers
blazers
rockets thunder jazz nuggets clippers
mavericks
yeah those are the ones that are left so
still some some series left still teams
fighting for a win trying to make it to
the second round so expect some big
finishes
how do you get the squad to meet that
standard
of you know day one of course you all
been there so how does that
play out i'm not smiling that's your
question
uh anthony is behind um
y'all i'm gonna call you anthony i think
you know no the brown's about to
play oh okay
[Music]
game over lakers one all right i only
have one game today
lakers blazers game three series is
split
who's winning it who's winning it today
[Music]
davis so the officiating in the bubble
so far has been a little
shaky it feels like they're calling
technicals on things that wouldn't
normally be texts
a lot of foul falls i wonder how much
the lack of a crowd has to do with that
but it hasn't been the best
[Music]
mavs versus clippers porzingis got
ejected and it was
weak we call sweet sauce
you know when it comes to playoff time
every single thing counts right and if
you aren't in the game people are
thinking about okay maybe the outcome
was different if kristaps was in the
game
how do you get over that thinking about
maybe what your absence did
yeah there's there's really not much to
do there you know you
you can think about the possibilities
but
but it is what it is at this point you
know we're already past this game and
we're gonna look at the
mistakes we've made and things we can do
better for the second game and
our belief is still strong that we can
beat these guys you know
and um and that's it if we didn't have
the
belief we shouldn't be here anyway so
that's our mindset going to the second
game
this is the face of a very sad person
i'm sad because yesterday i missed the
overtime game between the ruckus and the
thunder
then today i miss a monster performance
by luca
and an ot win from the mavericks beating
the clippers
and tying up the series because i didn't
submit for that game
i missed it probably the best game of
the bubble
hey dan so obviously last game you have
57 points today you have 30.
how have you almost become you know a
chameleon you can always adapt to like
what the team needs from you at any
given
moment or any given game probably thank
you the biggest thing for me is just
trying to like you said just
reading the situation you know i think
um i said earlier like the first my
first few years i kind of saw
the rim you know and being explored now
was kind of you know i prided myself on
the quarantine just kind of becoming a
playmaker you know
finding ways to get team involved but it
may not always be you know
scoring you know and i think today just
really trusted my teammates and
they did a hell of a job to me i mean
ruby joe jc royce everybody
you know to be able to not just hit
shots but be ready and make plays i
think that's what made it easy for me
okay i'm here at jazz versus nuggets
when i had rudy gobert on my show one
year he was talking about how
people don't pay attention to the team
as much as they should because it's in
utah
and he's kind of right media is usually
full at these games it's really just me
and rita
hanging out say i say it all this time
just to get a close-up of your hair
end up in the hands of galileo how much
do you do
i can't hear over here thanks i can't
hear you do heavies thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
sitting here waiting for the lakers
blazers to start right now
thunder rockets game is in ot the
thunder are up
the rockets haven't scored once in all
of overtime
i am sick that i'm missing it
okay during our game break eating food
but magic are playing the bucks
they're up like 20 points so i think
everybody might have overreacted after
game one
the raptors just swept the nets
advancing to the second round
but fred van vliet didn't want any
basketball questions asked at his press
conference
he only wanted to talk about jacob blake
who was shot by the police in the back
multiple times
um he was incredibly thoughtful visibly
emotional
had some tears in his eyes but he is
another example of players trying to say
you know even though we are in the
playoffs
there are other things happening in the
world that are more important
hey fred so you know i know that you
know pulling up your phone and seeing
people that look like you being killed
by the police can be a lot so
i guess my question is just how are you
how are you doing mentally
i'm a little bit you know all over the
place like i said you
um start to feel guilty a little bit um
you know there's a lot of stuff going on
for me back home you know
people in my own community you know uh
dying not by the hands of police was
just about product of the environment
so you try to take all that in and we're
here we're isolated
um my family got to town yesterday i
don't get to see them for another week
so
you know it would be nice to hug and
kiss on my kids a little bit
um but yeah you just try to deal with it
and
it's a lot to take in i think we can't
uh
underestimate the the trauma that that
we
take in on a daily basis from our phones
and watching these videos and
you know she watched uh watch a guy get
shot
you know in front of his entire family
and then right
underneath that video is somebody saying
hey well he should have just listened to
the police so like
like you you take all that in whether
you register it or not whether you
realize
what you're looking at or not like
you're taking that in and that
depreciation of life and
and you know kind of the you get numb to
to what you're looking at and you almost
start to question yourself like damn
like
maybe he should have listened and you
start to think like and then you snap
back to reality like nah that's not
that's not right so it's a lot of
emotions to take in you just try to stay
level-headed and bounce ideas off of
you know we got a tight group here so
like i said we had a chance to speak
this morning and
however you see fit to to get that that
out you do
um but it's a lot and we're in the
middle of it i mean it's fresh
so it's fresh but every time it's fresh
it brings back old
stuff and reopens wounds and my father
was killed when i was young so like it's
just a lot of
things that go into uh you know taking
all this
information in
[Music]
[Music]
there are no players on the floor the
clock hit zero players came out and
warmed up but went back and it
seems like the chatter is there will be
no
game five today
yes
[Music]
our focus today cannot be on basketball
we are calling for justice for jacob
blake
and demand the officers be held
accountable okay august 27th
a day after the nba postponed their
games as players sat
out in support of racial equality and
social justice
i just got off phone with some people um
and what i'm hearing about the joint
call between the owners and players is
that it was incredibly
productive um the main point was players
stressed that they wanted there to be a
dedicated coalition that worked within
the nba
whose full-time job was to support
um certain causes um
at a grassroots level local activists
funding them
supporting them amplifying their voice a
full-time coalition dedicated to that
i hear lebron james the last player to
speak on that call and he stressed to
the owners that this has to
be something that they care about past
the basketball season
michael jordan was also on that call and
was an incredibly
strong voice as well friday august 28th
this is the first day of practices
since the players decided to strike and
not play
these days of basketball games i'm
headed to
the clippers practice hey doc so we talk
a lot about perspective
but in years to come when history tells
the story about these past couple days
what story do you wanted to tell oh man
say that's too deep
um you know i want them to tell
the story about what they're speaking
about
now that the league is doing something
whenever that story is told uh they're
talking about what's happening
at that moment that it started then
the reason i say that that means they're
still doing
um and this i'm just hoping
is now one one type one hit wonder thing
this has to
continue and i think that's why the
coalition is so important
uh because this is not about just today
something's gonna happen next week
next month um and we have to have a
group in place
to understand how to handle that and
understand how to help the players
process
through it um and and we have to have
a group that is working on legislation
uh
all the time not just um you know u.s
but with state to state legislation and
so
um i think that's the story that i want
to
thank you thanks guys thank you thanks
for the deep question appreciate it
no problem the past couple days it's
a change for the greater good of the
future you know when you see
change happening in the future you can
look back and say that was the moment
when it happened
and that was a key moment when it
happened
you know i would say the the bubble
season would never be forgotten when it
comes to sports it's
the first time we've been able to do
something like this but obviously
you know this moment is so much bigger
than us playing basketball so
um hopefully the initiatives that we
came together that we partnered with
voting and the sites and the arenas and
things of that nature hopefully
years on down the down the line when
america is in a better place
that you can look back to this moment
and be like that was one of the
counterparts that kind of
got to go want to shed some light on
what nba coaches are doing to help this
movement
um they are playing such a big role in
amplifying
the voices of the voiceless i was just
on the phone with atlanta hogs head
coach lloyd pierce and he was actually
in the car waiting for a call from jacob
blake
senior trying to figure out what they
can do to help the situation
um i also recently learned that mavs
head coach rick carlisle played a
pivotal role in some policy change in
dallas
he worked alongside local activists
august 29th
the games are starting back up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh your fist is so much bigger
than mine
it's working it's going up
three more
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't feel good about this for the
jazz
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
final score
utah
let's go
round two
hey donovan um i know you walked us
through the final play and what was
going through your head then but once
that was over you were on the floor for
a bit
can you walk me through the emotions
that you felt on the ground
to be honest with you i'm in shock um
that was really it you know i think the
biggest thing was you worked so hard as
a unit as a whole to get to a point that
we got to
and we were this close you know
to be that close that hurts
and i really know what else to do
i was exhausted uh i just kind of just
laid there
i don't know man i just that [ __ ] sucks
um it'll be on my mind for a long time
it kind of reminds me of last year going
forward 23 from the field
i kind of fielded my entire season in
game five against houston in houston
and fueled everything i did this year
just another thing to feel me for next
year and
i'll be back we'll be back um
but that's really what that was
[Applause]
[Music]
okc ball 1.1
seconds left the anxiety this is enough
time
catching shoes
[Music]
round one was incredibly eventful uh to
say the least
we started off watching some players
play very competitive basketball
then there was a pause because players
wanted to use their voice
protest against police brutality and
racism that happens in this country
round one's over round two is set
and we'll see you then